6 27 on your friday morning what's cool  at school how about letting you decide  which of many projects you want to  support and knowing the silver state has  teachers backs  the nevada department of education  recently announced a collaboration with  the teacher funding website donors  choose to help them spend eight million  dollars in federal relief money on  pandemic related projects  whether it's helping high schoolers with  their mindfulness meditation  chipping in on computer stuff for an  elementary classroom or dozens of other  nevada projects the choice is yours and  we've got the link to the donors choose  website and the online version of this  story check out our website and if you  know something that's cool at school let  us know head to eightnewsdown.com look  for the community tab that's where  you'll find cool at school or just send  us an email cool at school at  8newsnow.com